I think the best way to followup with
somebody you met at a networking event
that made an impression is, of course,
send them a thank you email.
But it's really about finding that
one thing you spoke about in your
conversation that you want to mention
again in that email that would
make this email specific and
not a generic email that the person
thinks you sent out to everyone.
I think also having an action
item is a great thing.
Perhaps, following up with a coffee
chat or a Skype call or maybe you talked
about an interesting topic and if this
followup email will include an article
about this or something that
you wrote or found recently.
Trying to make a connection after
the event is just as important,
if not more important,
than the connection in the event